Çeviri: Sessenol Projesi
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Ben Ekonometri okudum ve otomotiv
sektöründe sıradan bir çalışanım.
Dolayısıyla burada bulunma sebebim;
ne ekonominin seyrinden bahsetmek,
ne otomotiv sektöründeki
gelişmeleri anlatmak.
Zaten yapamam.
Benim burada bulunmam,
gezgin sıfatım dolayısıyla.
Aslında herkes geziyor.
Gençler arasında gezmek
çok moda bir hâle dönüştü.
Ekstrem geziler, otostop ile geziler,
bisiklet ile geziler,
motosiklet ile
çok uzak yolculuklar yapıyorlar
ve her yolculuk da
aslında bir riski barındırıyor.
Sanırım benim aldığım riskler
asıl merak uyandıran şeydi,
yolculuklarıma nazaran.
Bir insan tek başına neden
Afganistan, Pakistan, Irak, Filistin,
Etiyopya gibi pek çok ülkeye
tek başına seyahatlere gider?
Cemil Meriç’in çok sevdiğim bir sözü var.
Diyor ki, “Yaşamak yaralanmaktır
ve yaralanmak güzel.''
Yakın çevremdeki insanlar
genellikle fiziksel yaralanmalarımdan
endişe ediyorlardı
ama benim gittiğim coğrafyalarda
en çok endişe ettiğim şey;
ruhsal yaralanmalarımın şiddetiydi.
Şimdi buraya döneceğim ama öncesinde
bir psikolog edası ile
küçüklüğünüze dönelim diyorum.
En geriye gidebildiğim
3-4 yaşlarımdan aklımda kalan
babamın ben ve abime,
Jules Verne’in Ay’a Yolculuk,
Denizler Altında 20 Bin Fersah gibi
pek çok kitabı okuduğuydu.
Anlamıyordum aslında çok fazla.
'Ay’a Yolculuk' kitabı,
1865 yılında yazılmış
Jules Verne tarafından.
Ay’a da biliyorsunuz
1969 yılında gidildi.
Yani tam 104 yıl sonra.
Babam bu kitaptaki yolculuğun
gerçek Ay’a yolculukla
ne kadar benzediğini,
ne kadar yakın olduğunu anlatırdı
ve insanın hayal kurmasının,
zihnini açık bırakmasının,
ne kadar değerli olduğundan bahsederdi.
“Sen elinde bir taş varsa onu at.
O suda oluşan harelerin
nereye varacağını bilemezsin.” derdi.
Tabii bütün okuduğum romanlar,
karşılaştığım şeyler,
çok mutlu sonla bitmiyordu.
Ben hikâyeleri küçüklük aklımla
yeniden yazıyordum.
1966 yapımı ‘Her Devrin Adamı’
diye bir film var.
Belki izleyenleriniz vardır.
8. Henry ve Thomas More’un
gerçek hikâyesi.
Yine onu ailecek izlerken
ben ortadan kayboluyorum.
Baktıkları zaman kâğıdı, kalemi almışım.
Thomas More’u idama götüren,
çok ilkeli, aristokrat, düzgün bir adam.
İdama götürüyor 8. Henry
ve bu kararın olduğunu anladığım
andan itibaren kaybolmuşum
ve hikâyeyi yeniden yazmışım.
Ama büyümeye başladıkça artık
bir kâğıt, kalem ile mutlu sonlar
yaratamayacağımı fark ettim.
Çevremde savaşlar oluyor,
açlıktan insanlar ölüyor,
her gün terör haberlerini görüyorum
ve ben bunun
sessiz tanıklarından bir tanesiyim.
“Vah vah, tüh tüh, yazık,
Allah iyilik versin, Allah sabır versin”
diyordum ve sonrasında da
kendime savunma mekanizmaları
geliştiriyordum.
Çünkü mutlu bir şekilde
hayatımı idame ettirmek istiyordum
ama özümle olan bağı
kopartmaya başlamıştım.
Mesela Anti Aging merkezleri olmuştu.
Ben yaşlanmaktan korkuyordum.
Dolayısıyla bu bana mutluluk veriyordu.
Ya da savaşlardan korkmaya başlamıştım.
O cesur kız artık
dünyaları kurtaran aklında korkular sahibi
olmaya başlamıştı büyümeye başladıkça.
Savaşlardan korkum yüzünden,
Savunma Sanayi adı altında
silah üretimini, silah satın alınmasını
uygun buluyordum.
Yani her türlü korkumu sermayeleştiren
bir dünyanın kollarındaydım
ve o çarkın bir parçası olmuştum.
Arkadaşlarımla
eğlenceli turlara gidiyordum;
Uzak Doğu, Amerika,
hemen hemen bütün Avrupa ülkeleri.
Hepsini gezmiştim
ama beni asıl etkileyen şey;
kendi gerçekliğimden dışarıya çıkmama
vesile olan gezilerdi.
Televizyon izlerken;
bir mazlum, bir zalim, bir haklı,
bir haksız ilan ediyordum.
Haberleri görünce ve zalime karşı,
haksıza karşı
inanılmaz bir öfke duyuyordum.
O sırada İzzeldin Abuelaısh’in
‘Nefret Etmeyeceğim’
adlı kitabını almıştım.
Kitabı yazan Gazzeli bir doktor, idealist.
Howerdlı bir doktor.
3 kızının da İsrailli tanklar tarafından
öldürülmesine tanıklık ediyor.
Sonrasında söylediği şey
beni çok etkilemişti.
Diyor ki, “İnşallah benim kızlarım
İsrail ve Filistin arasında
barışa giden yolda son kurbanlar olurlar.”
Böyle bir bakış nasıl bir bakıştı?
Ben dışarıdan, bu acı ile yüzleşmemişken
çok büyük öfke duyarken
öfkesinin üzerine çıkabilmiş bir insanın
kitabını okuduğum zaman,
o acizliğim yüzüme çarpıldı ve dedim ki:
“Ben bu topraklara gitmek istiyorum.
Bu gerçekliğe
kendim temas etmek istiyorum.”
Gazze ve Batı Şeria
İsrail tarafından ayrılmış,
Gazze’ye giriş çok zor nasıl gidebilirim?
diye atladım ve gittim.
Öncelikle Kudüs’e gittim
ve bu en koyu Yahudilerin,
en koyu Müslümanların,
en koyu Hristiyanların merkezi.
Bu dinlerin, sevgiyi ve barışı
öğreten dinlerin merkezini
bu öğretinin mensuplarına
karşı silahlar koruyordu.
Nasıl bir paradoks ise?
Her tarafta İsrailli askerler,
silahlı İsrail askerleri doluydu.
Bir minibüse atlayarak Ramallah,
Beytüllahim, El-Halil’e gittim.
Orada insanlarla konuşmaya çalıştım
ama benim ajan olabileceğimi düşündüler.
Ya da İsrail tarafından
gönderilmiş bir insan olacağım,
laf almaya çalışıyorum şeklinde düşünüldü.
Ama konuşabildiğim,
sohbet edebildiğim insanlar da oldu.
Herkesin işkenceye,
hapse atılmaya dair hikâyeleri vardı.
Bir çocuk ile tanıştım.
Lise çağlarında bir çocuk.
Hem bir taraftan yurtdışına gitmek,
orada yaşamını sürdürmek,
bir taraftan da Filistin'de kalmak
ve ülkesini korumak istiyordu.
Bir hikâye anlatılır alegori olarak.
2. Dünya savaşından sonra
atom bombasından
nasıl korunabileceğimizin anlatıldığı,
bir dersten sonra küçük kız evine gelir
ve annesine der ki,
“Anne, gökyüzü olmayan
bir yere taşınamaz mıyız?”
O da savaş olmayan
bir yere taşınmak istiyordu.
Filistin’de bu tanıştığım insanların
kimileri ile bağlantım devam etti.
Çok başarılı bir çocuktu Muhammed.
Amerika’da okumak istiyordu.
Okul birincisiydi.
Amerika’da öğretim görevlisi
bir tanıdığım vardı.
‘Nasıl burs alabilir?’
Araştırdık beraberce.
Muhammed ile onu kontağa soktum
ve seneye Amerika’da okuyacak İnşallah.
Daha sonra Afrika’ya gittim.
Bir İtalyan kız arkadaşım
burada bana eşlik etti.
Önce Addis Ababa’ya gittik,
daha sonra bir araç kiraladık.
Yürüyerek gitmek için çok tehlikeliydi.
Güney’e ilkel kabilelere doğru
yolculuk yapmaya başladık
ve Güney’e giderken yanımıza
bir sürü de hediyeler aldık kendimizce.
Karşılaştığım hayat kendi gerçekliğimden
dışarıya çıkarak, kendi konfor alanımdan,
güvenlik alanımdan çıkarak gördüğüm
hayat beni bambaşka bir yere sürüklemişti.
Güney’e, ilkel kabilelere indiğimiz zaman
insanlar bizden korktular.
Biz de onlardan korktuk aslında.
Tehlikeli miyiz, tehlikeliler mi ?
Beyaz olarak gördükleri için
çeşitli yerlerime dokundular,saçlarıma
dokundular, birbirimizi inceledik.
Her yeni gün yeni bir yaşam mücadelesiydi.
Avlanmak ile başlıyordu ve sonrasında
yaşama tutunma çabası ile devam ediyordu.
Bir kalemin ya da en ufak bir hediyenin
bir insan üzerinde
bu kadar mutluluk yarattığını,
modern çağdan çıkmış bir insan olarak
ilk kez bu kadar yakinen gözlemliyordum.
Orada yaşadıklarım çok özeldi belki
ama döndükten sonraki içsel yolculuğum
daha da zorlayıcıydı benim için.
Çünkü başka bir boyuta taşınmıştı
artık idrakım.
Tanzimat aydınlarından
Ziya Paşa’nın bir lafı vardır.
Der ki, “Ya Rab, niçin bu arsada
her şahs-ı ârifin Mikdâr-ı fazlına göre
derdi olur füzun?”
Yani neden bu dünyada insanların
idrakının, aklının arttığı ölçüde
dertleri de artar?
Sorgulamasak, daha çok bilmeyi
daha çok mutlu olmak uğruna feda etsek
hayat daha mı güzel olur acaba?
Ben idrakım başka bir boyuta taşındıktan
sonra evet acı çeker olmuştum
ama meselelerim değişmişti
dertlerim değişmişti.
İnsanların, herkesin acı çektiğini
düşünüyorum ama acısını atfettiği olaylar
idrak durumuna göre
birbirinden farklılık gösteriyor.
Acıyı en çok ben burada gördüm.
Şarbat Gula.
79-89 Sovyet İstilası sonunda bir
Afgan kızı mülteci kampında yaşıyor
ve 84 yılında National Geographic
fotoğrafçıları fotoğrafını çekiyor.
Acıyı, gözlerindeki korkuyu o kadar güzel
yansıtmış ki, bu onu dünyanın en bilinen
fotoğraflarından bir tanesi yapıyor.
Orada kadınların durumu
gerçekten çok acı.
Ben burada ‘Acaba bir şey yapabilir miyiz?
Görmek istedim bunu
ve Afganistan’a gittim.
Afganistan evden her çıkışın geri dönüp
dönemeyeceğinizin bilinmezliğinde
yaşandığı bir coğrafya.
Kadının tamamıyla hayattan tecrit edildiği
yaşamın çok ağır koşullarda gerçekleştiği,
çok az sayıda zengin insanın
çelik duvarlar arasında yaşamını
devam ettirdiği, paranın gayrikanuni
yollardan genellikle kazanıldığı,
devletin varlığının hissedilmediği
Taliban terörün her an hissedildiği
ve tehlikenin nereden geldiğini,
geleceğini bilmediğiniz
bir coğrafya Afganistan.
Orada pek çok kadın ile tanıştım.
Ulaşmaya çalıştım,
kadın derneklerinin başında
ama onlar da
çok büyük hayati tehlikeler içerisinde.
Afganistan’da aileme iyi olduğumun
haberini verebilmek için
bir otel lobisine girdim.
İnternete bağlanmaya çalışırken
Ahsan adında bir çocukla tanıştım.
18-19 yaşlarında.
Onun da İngilizcesi oldukça iyiydi.
Aslında bir kadının bir erkekle konuşması
oldukça ekstrem bir durum orada.
Ben konuşmayı başlattım.
Bana dedi ki, “Biz bu topraklarda diğer
coğrafyalarda olduğu gibi
anne-babamızın hayalleri ile büyüyoruz.
Çocuğum doktor olacak, avukat olacak gibi.
Ama çoğu çocuk hayallerine yaklaşamadan
hayatını kaybediyor
çünkü biz terörün içine doğuyoruz.
Başka bir ülkeye gitmek istiyoruz,
hayatımızı kurtarmak istiyoruz
ama dünyanın gözünde
biz potansiyel teröristiz, Afganız.
Ben hayallerimin gerçekleşebileceği
ümidini taşıyarak
yaşamımı devam ettirebilmek
istiyorum dedi.
O sırada internete bağlandım.
Az önce geçtiğim yerlerde bir intihar
bombasının patladığı haberini gördüm.
Onunla bunu konuştuk.
Olmak ve olmamak arasındaki mesafesizlik
orada benim yüzüme çarptı ve bana dedi ki,
Ahsan, “Neyse, sen nasıl olsa
gidebileceksin buradan.”
Afganistan’dan sonra bir diğer
savaş içerisinde olan coğrafya Irak.
Bu defa biletimi Irak’a aldım.
Mülteci kamplarına gittim.
Mülteci kamplarında
pek çok insan ile tanıştım.
Çadırlarına beni konuk ettiler.
8-9 kişinin beraber yaşadığı çadırlar.
Ümitli, ümitsiz, mutlu, mutsuz, zor
durumda, hasta pek çok insan ile tanıştım.
Pek çok insan hikâyesi toplayabildim
ve bir aileye konuk olduğum zaman
bu beni çok etkiledi.
Çadırlarında yemeklerini, içeceklerini
büyük bir özveri ile bana açtılar.
Hep beraber yedik, içtik, konuştuk.
Sincar Dağı'nda eşinin Işid tarafından
öldürüldüğünü anlatan
bir kadın bana dedi ki,
“Seni burada çok iyi ağırlayamadım.
Şu savaşlar bitsin de
bana da gel, evime de gel.”
Bu ümidi görmek benim için
çok etkileyiciydi.
Daha sonra 16 yaşında
bir çocuk ile konuştum.
Dedi ki, “Ben Amerika’da okuyacağım.”
Sonra orada koşturup
top oynayan çocukları gösterip dedi ki,
“Onları da yanıma alacağım.”
Ümit sahibi olmanın hayatta
ne kadar değerli olduğunu
ve insanın yaşamını
devam ettirebilmesi için
yegane güç olduğunu
ben ardı ardına okuduğum
Stefan Zweig ve Viktor Frankl
hikâyesinde çok iyi görmüştüm.
Stefan Zweig Yahudi bir yazar.
Viktor Frankl da öyle.
2. Dünya Savaşı patlak verdiği sıralarda
eşi ile beraber Brezilya’ya kaçıyorlar.
Viktor Frankl’da yakalanıyor.
Onun kadar şanslı değil
ve toplama kampına götürülüyor.
Viktor Frankl çok ağır koşullarda
burada yaşamını devam ettiriyor.
Ailesi gözlerinin önünde katlediliyor.
Koşullar gerçekten bir insanın
kaldıramayacağı boyutta ancak ümidi var.
Bunu nereden anlıyoruz ? ‘İnsanın Anlam
Arayışı’ kitabından daha sonra yazdığı.
Stefan Zweig ise bu gerçeklikten uzakta,
1942 yılında artık Yahudiler için
bir gelecek görmediği için
karısı ile beraber intihar ediyor.
Aralarındaki tek fark biri ümit sahibi,
o zorlukların içerisinde dayanabiliyor.
Birisi o zorlukların dışında
ama ümidini kaybetmiş.
Ben insan hikâyeleri dinlemenin
çok değerli olduğunu düşünüyorum.
Biz işitsel bir toplumuz.
Her ne kadar yüzümüz Batı’ya baksa da
aslında köklerini
Doğu’dan alan bir toplumuz
ve bizde irfan, ilim
atalarımızdan, babalarımızdan geçerdi
hikâyeler anlatılırdı hep.
Biz artık hikâye dinlemeye zaman bulamayan
insanlar hâline dönüştük.
Hikâye insanlar arasında bağ kurmak
dışında insanın kendi özü ile de
bağ kurmasını sağlıyor.
Benim için hızlı hayat sadece sürekli
etkinlik içerisinde olmak değil,
insanın özü ile kurduğu bağı güçlendirecek
etkinlikler içerisinde olmamak demek.
Sözlerime Cemil Meriç ile başlamıştım.
Diyordu ki, “Yaşamak yaralanmaktır,
yaralanmak güzel.”
Bu yaralardan insanlığımın
açığa çıkması dileğiyle.
Teşekkürler.